bonsoir
pour commencer je vais vous demander de
partir avec moi dans un voyage dans le
temps et dans l'espace
on va faire un petit retour de 80 années
en arrière et on va aller à cambridge en
angleterre et on va entrer dans le
bureau à king's collège de l'économiste
john maynard keynes et si vous faites un
calcul rapide
vous voyez que ça nous emmène vers les
années 30
et vous pensez aux problèmes qui se
posent à l'époque c'est la grande crise
c'est la dépression dans pratiquement en
tout cas tous les pays occidentaux et
kate réfléchit il réfléchit et il pose
la question suivante se pose la question
suivante est ce qu'on pourra arriver de
mai à mettre tout le monde d'accord est
ce qu'on peut vraiment essayé de base
est une société sûre le consen sus où on
ne prendrait des décisions qu à
l'unanimité et que tout le monde soit
d'accord sur tout et puis dit non ce
n'est pas possible
vous le savez pourquoi des goûts et des
couleurs il ya des tempéraments
différents et des gens qui sont plus
voilà au plus ouvert plus ferme etc et
s'est dit non c'est pas possible
mais qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas réfléchir
dans l'autre sens dans l'autre direction
ou fait qu'il ya des gens qui sont très
malheureux qui a beaucoup de gens qui
ont ce ressentiment vis-à-vis du système
tel qu'il est organisé et non sans
raison parce que voilà il ya beaucoup
d'inégalités à des choses qui sont ils
sont à juste est-ce qu'on ne pourrait
pas réfléchir dans l'autre sens et se
demander si on ne pourrait pas minimisé
dans une société le nombre de gens qui
sont mal yeux malheureux minimiser leur
et sentiments l'adie satisfaction la
satisfaction dans une population et
s'est dit oui ça c'est possible ça c'est
beaucoup plus réalisable que de mettre
tout le monde d'accord sur tout il
réfléchit à ce moment là il se dit
qu'est ce qui pourrait dans une société
comme la nôtre au obtenir ces résultats
du malheur tombé à son à son minimum et
dans le cadre de la dépression la
réponse lui viendrait facilement c'est
le plein emploi le plein emploi
il faut que l'on mobilise
toutes les ressources en vue du plein
emploi il le dit à l'époque
ce n'est pas la solution économique
optimal mais il dit aux problèmes dont
on nous dit que ce sont des problèmes
économiques
la réponse n'est pas nécessairement
économique elle doit être politique au
sens du mot politique c'est à dire la
police la société dans laquelle nous
vivons
organiser la société qui est autour de
nous alors si on voulait résoudre les
difficultés dans notre société on
pourrait reprendre la solution de keynes
et dire on va essayer de réorganiser à
nouveau le plein emploi
mais là il ya une difficulté il ya
d'ailleurs qu'il avait prévu lui même
dans un article consignes beaucoup
maintenant je crois un article du début
des années 30 le chômage structurel
il va y avoir de plus en plus de gens
qui vont être remplacés dans leur
travail par une machine
et cette machine c'est pas
nécessairement voilà un robot ça peut
être un logiciel
ça peut être un algorithme commandiez
les sténodactylo et ont disparu
entièrement n'ont pas été remplacés par
un robot elles ont été remplacées par
les traitements texte beaucoup de
comptable qui faisait des calculs sur
dix sur des bouts de papier avec un
crayon avec une règle à calcul et ils
ont disparu ils ont remplacé par le par
le tableur il ya plein de métiers qui
sont en train de disparaître l'emploi
disparaît de manière massive ou verrait
ses études on en parle beaucoup qui nous
disent que dans l'horizon 2030
30% des emplois dans tel secteur ont
disparu hier une étude qui est paru il
ya quelques jours et qui nous dit qu'à
l'horizon de saab 200 ans à l'horizon de
cent ans plus personne ne sera
nécessaire dans un travail et quand on y
réfléchit c'est du chose que nous avons
voulu on a vous avons voulu moi j'étais
gosse dans les années 50 les années 50
on nous parlait de l'an 2000 et l'an
2000 c'est une vision extraordinaire
c'était splendide en l'an 2000 on
seraient remplacés par des machines et
on avait tous on passerait beaucoup plus
de temps à des activités créatives
connaîtrez tout cela musée quand j'aurai
tout d'un instrument on irait pour nous
promener dans la nature avec nos enfants
puis avec nos petits enfants le
remplacement par la machine et eu lieu
il est en train de se faire
mais on avait oublié une chose dans les
années 50 c'est que la personne qui a
remplacé dans son travail
et bien ne reçoit pas de l'argent pour
le faire au contraire on l'occupé pas
blizz de plus en plus et dans notre
société où de moins en moins d'emplois
les gens seront de plus en plus
culpabiliser et si les gens qui avaient
encore un travail c'est de défendre
leurs positions deviendra de plus en
plus faible parce que il y aura trop de
concurrence
une étude nous montre quand on quand on
remplace on quand on introduit un robot
pour mille dans la population il ya
quatre cinq emplois qui disparaissent
mais encore pire les salaires de tout le
monde baisse d'un pour cent
pourquoi parce que la concurrence
augmente entre ceux qui restent et qui
se battent pour les emplois alors si le
plein emploi n'est plus une possibilité
pour nous comme la chose à laquelle nous
pouvons rêver
qu'est ce que à part quoi peut-on le
remplacer car j'ai commencé à réfléchir
un petit peu à ça et pour moi les choses
sont sympathiques loyer on m'a vite on
me demande de faire des conférences je
pense à l'argent de temps en temps dans
la journée parce qu'on me demande parce
qu'il ya des factures à régler cetera et
je regarde sur mon compte en banque et
puis je peux régler les sommes et c'est
formidable mais il ya une époque dans ma
vie en fait il ya eu plusieurs époques
dans ma gibout gens de talent que
j'avais seul intéressé en fait personne
n'a été assez personnes et là je pensais
à ce moment là je pensé à l'argent
peut-être une fois par minute dans la
journée parce qu'on m'a réclamé de
l'argent avec quatre enfants à charge et
je n'avais pas l'argent mais quand je
dis une fois par minute c'était
peut-être une fois toutes les 30
secondes
et si vous connaissez cette situation si
vous êtes passé par là si vous n'êtes
peut-être même dans cette situation
aujourd'hui vous savez ce que ça fait ce
genre de réflexion de penser trop pas
l'argent ça détruit les familles détruit
les familles et ça fait pleurer les
petits enfants d'une manière qu'on a du
mal à arrêter alors je pensais à ça et
le lendemain matin quand je me suis
réveillée
j'avais ma réponse à la question que de
penser à la place du plein emploi de
keynes aujourd'hui un monde sans argent
le cauchemar à gauche marque
disparaîtrait entièrement pour peut-être
pas tous d'entre nous avons peut-être de
la chance mais pour beaucoup d'entre
nous un cauchemar disparaîtrait du jour
au lendemain
alors on nous dira le dit oui mais bon
vous rêvez utopie et cetera on n'est pas
assez riche pour faire ça on n'est pas
assez riche pour faire ça vous
connaissez ce chiffre c'est oxfam qui le
fait circuler aujourd'hui dans le monde
oui personne en termes de richesse de
patrimoine l'équivalent de la moitié de
l'humanité
3 7 milliards de personnes oui personne
d'un côté 3,7 milliards vous savez ce
que c'est 3 7 me à la première fois que
je fais un exposé je me suis trompé
3 cette fois mille fois mille fois mille
trois fois j'avoue bien mille tellement
le chiffre est énorme
oui personnes qui ont les mêmes
ressources que la moitié de l'humanité
l'amanite et l'humanité la moelle à la
plus pauvre bien entendu
josemi ça parce que je vais le lire on
va le lire ensemble le plus grand bien
qu'elle le premier objet de la société
c'est de maintenir les droits
imprescriptibles de l'homme
quel est le premier de ces droits celui
d'exister
la première loi sociale et donc celle
qui garantit à tous les membres de la
société les moyens d'exister toutes les
autres sont subordonnés à celle là les
aliments nécessaires à lui l'homme sont
aussi sacrée que la vie elle-même tout
ce qui est indispensable pour la
conserver est une propriété commune à la
société entière
il n'ya que l'excédent qui soit une
propriété individuelle et qui soit
abandonnée à l'industrie des commerçants
quel est le problème à résoudre en
matière de législation sur les
subsistances
le voici assurer à tous les membres de
la société la jouissance de la portion
des fruits de la terre qui est
nécessaire à leur existence aux
propriétaires et aux cultivateurs le
prix leur industrie et livrées le
superflu à la liberté du commerce je
défie les plus scrupuleux défense de la
propriété de contester ces principes à
moins de déclarer ouvertement qu'il
entend par ce mot le droit de dépouiller
et d'assassiner ses semblables
le problème la législation des
subsistances
bon cela nous met la puce à l'oreille
c'est pas maintenant on parle pas comme
ça qu'est-ce qui parle qui officie à
parler comme ça qui est ce qui a fait ce
discours bien c'est un certain
maximilien robespierre à certains
maximilien robespierre c'est un mot qui
fait peur on dit sanguinaire qui rend
etc
c'est un mot c'est un nom dont on ne
sait pas trop ce qui de ce qu'il faut en
penser
de nos jours il faut peut-être se
remettre un petit peu dans dont
l'atmosphère quand même temps il a dit
ça les troupes étrangères avaient envahi
la france par le nord et par parent
laisse la guerre civile
vous le savez régner au sein de la
france à différents endroits
tout le monde n'était pas d'accord avec
l'idée de la de la révolution alors
qu'est ce qu'il a proposé
il était naïf il faut lire c'était là un
naïf il a proposé que tout le monde
s'adonne à la vertu et il a vu
malheureusement que tout le monde
pouvait pas s'adonner à la vertu et il a
imposé
effet la terreur et il est mort avec la
foule qui criait là qu'on voit là la
convention moreau tirons retirant mais
je voudrais quand même encore une autre
chose à propos de robespierre vous
souvenez comme on l'appelait on l'a
appelé l'incorruptible mais alors si un
sublime et les journaux si vous écoutez
la radio c'est regarder la télévision
ces jours ci vous verrez que c'est un
terme qu'on a vraiment du mal à
appliquer de nos jours à beaucoup de
personnes et je n'ai pas le sentiment
que même dans l'histoire on ait voulu
appliquer ce terme à beaucoup de
personnes alors il faut y penser à
robespierre il a parlé de cela le
premier ses droits c'est celui d'exister
ça me semble une chose absolument
indispensable et vous l'aï compris ce
qu'il proposait c'est ce que sur
l'indispensable l'indispensable soit
gratuit
le reste le superflu ce qui en plus on
peut le laisser avec dans les mains du
du commerce
alors quand on parle de gratuité c'est
pas quelque chose que nous donne jobs
nous n'avons jamais entendu parler il ya
une époque où l'éducation
l'instruction était gratuite on trouvait
ça normal au moment où l'instaurer on a
trouvé ça formidable
et puis on a perdu l'idée un tout petit
peu il ya une époque pas si lointaine on
appelle ça des trente glorieuses où la
santé et est gratuite eh bien on
pourrait commencer par revenir la
gratuité sur ces choses là sur
l'indispensable ce qui permet aux gens
de vivre
alors on se pose la question parce qu'il
est vraiment possible de payer pour
cette gratuité qu'est-ce qui vous
trouverez ton les ressources qui nous
permettrait de payer pour sa retraite
plus gratuite et de l'indispensable et
c'est là qu'il faut revenir la réflexion
sur le plein emploi la personne la
personne qui remplaçait dans un travail
ne bénéficie par une machine que ce soit
un logiciel que ce soit de
l'informatique du numérique ça n'a pas
d'importance
la personne qui est remplacée
aujourd'hui par le processus de
l'automation où la mécanisation n'en
bénéficient pas il y avait un philosophe
au suisse au début du 19e siècle quand
les années 1810 s'appelait sismondi
sismondi y réfléchissait à l'époque où
lui dit l'élu dit c'est et les ouvriers
qui étaient remplacés par des machines
et qui allait détruire les machines
pourquoi parce qu'il ne bénéfice ait
bénéficié pas du fait d'avoir été
remplacé et 6 mondial dit la chose
suivante il a dit le la mécanisation
c'est un bénéfice pour l'humanité toute
entière il faut que ces bénéfices soient
partagées et en particulier que celui
qui est remplacé par la machine
bénéficie d'une rente sur la richesse
qui sera créé dorénavant à partir de
cette machine alors cette idée là je les
ressusciter en 2012
c'était dans une de ses chroniques que
je fais pour le journal le monde il ya
un candidat aux élections
vous avez le savez peut-être il
s'appelle monsieur benoît hamon qui a
repris c'est mon idée de la taxe robes
ou on l'appelle la taxe roubaud parce
que voilà parce que c'est plus simple de
dire la taxe sur la mécanisation moi je
l'appelle appelé au départ quand je
l'introduit l'idée de la taxe sismondi
alors cette taxe elle me permet elle
permettra à mon avis de commencer par
faire qu'à nouveau l'instruction soit
gratuite parce que vous savez que
l'instruction quand elle n'est pas
l'éducation quand elle n'est pas
gratuite
reprendre produit simplement de
génération en génération les privilèges
de certains et les difficultés des
autres on peut revenir à la gratuité sur
la santé et puis on peut continuer on
peut continuer quand on a quand on pense
au niveau local les transports locaux
eh bien il n'y a pas de raison qu'on
peut compter pour ça non j'étais je
faisais une conférence l'autre jour
habiterez à vitré et transports en
commun s'ouvre sont gratuits et puis on
pourra penser au logement ou logement
élémentaire pas des palais pour tout le
monde bien entendu on pourrait penser à
étendre le système des chèques repas qui
permet d'avoir de la nourriture de base
s'agit pas d'aller acheter des ortolans
du whisky avec ça
aux etats unis les food stamps food
stamm qui accueille c'est à dire des
boues d'aider des coupons qui vous
permettent d'acheter à manger et à boire
des choses élémentaires part du whisky
comme je viens de le dire
15% de la population bénéficie de sa la
gratuité c'est une idée qui nous est en
fait connu on peut la remettre en place
on peut faire que les dividendes que ce
que ce que la richesse créée par les
machines n'aille pas simplement
alimenter les dividendes à distribuer
aux actionnaires
ou alors ces sommes extraordinaires que
vous pouvez voir tous les jours tel
patron d'entreprise reçoit un bonus de
10 millions mais le journaliste vous
10,7 millions été plus correct que ces
sommes sont des sommes absolument
pharaonique est tout à fait obscène
il ne faudrait jamais accepter ça oui
personne n'a coûté trois milliards de
recettes de l'autre la question n'est
pas que nous soyons pas assez riches
la question c'est la distribution la
redistribution de la richesse qui crée
et pas simplement par un problème par
une fiscalité de type classique on va
peut prendre aux autres pour donner aux
autres
la machine la mécanisation nous avons
voulu cela nous avons voulu les robots
nous avons voulu les logiciels pas
individuellement mais de notre culture
notre civilisation l'a voulu il faut que
tout le monde en bénéficie et demain
matin je me réveillerai peut-être ce
sera peut-être pas exactement de même
dans les jours qui viennent et je me
réveillerai et je dirais
chmar est terminée l'argent a disparu il
n'y a plus d'argent
les petits enfants ne pleurerons plus
parce que leurs parents se disputent pas
ce qu'il y'a pas assez d'argent la
maison ce paradis auquel nous image
celle que nous imaginons souvent en nous
disant il faut le mettre ailleurs et
bien plus tard dans un autre monde nous
pouvons le réaliser ici merci
[Applaudissements]